you're uh I let's do it how is the art
of circling practitioner training making
a difference in your life
probably one of the most under taught
areas of existence is emotional
intelligence and the fact that there's a
group of people that are now becoming
worldwide that get together to practice
skills of authenticity transformation
active listening paraphrasing actually
showing each other deep empathy and
compassion and just being with those
feelings and not trying to fix people or
patch people up kind of like what
coaching does that is so fascinating and
that is such an important skill set to
both develop as somebody that is aiming
to work directly with someone as well as
be the receiver of that set of of
emotions so that's probably the most
important thing that I'm learning right
now at art of circling teacher training
and that's why it's so important to me
is developing out the skill sets of
emotional intelligence and then sharing
that with children in the future and
getting them to care about what
emotional intelligence will do for their
interpersonal bility as well as their
sociability as well as their rapport
building and how that affects your
family your relationships your business
all these different aspects of life how
is a house circling affecting your
relationships your work and your
happiness relationships work and
happiness how to circling effect those
things alright so the probably the first
thing that comes to mind is that the the
ability to really quickly talk to
somebody and get on their same vibe and
getting to get into their world and
whether that be in business in a family
member or in a relationship that the
idea that you know how to ask a really
good question
and then to just be an active listener
and paraphrase to make it very evident
that you're listening to them and that
you're caring for what they're saying
that that is directly applicable in
every single facet of life it makes you
happier makes your family members happy
or relationships happier and it also
will build a better world if we know how
to talk to each other with with our two
ears in one mouth
would you take back the growth to have
the tuition in your pocket and why every
single penny that you invest into your
education especially when it's off path
education so we're not talking about a
collegiate system we're talking about
off path education these paths that are
not walk down by most people the more
eccentric and unusual the path is the
more you should walk down it because it
usually has these beautiful golden
nuggets of wisdoms that are very
untapped into that you can learn a lot
from so every single penny that you
invest into a program like this or a
program that teaches you about
mindfulness or emotional intelligence or
how to relate with people is worth it
because also think about the compounding
effect it has if you don't go out the
door today and go and start practicing
these skills imagine if you waited a
year to go out and practice these skills
think about what you would have lost in
this last year by not investing in
yourself as soon as possible why are you
supporting this work why are you
supporting circle
so one of the most important things
that's been tried to communicate for the
last especially hundred years by people
that have unfortunately been either
assassinated or killed is World Peace
and the fact that we still have this as
a question in society means we're very
very unaware were very disconnected the
fact that World Peace is just still up
yeah that doesn't really matter that
there's no way that happened we will
always fight for war always fight for
land always religion always money there
always be something to fight about once
we get world peace there will be war
because there has to be something like
that no no it's time to envision a world
where nobody is suffering for clean
water clean food shelter education or
health care it's time to envision that
world where you get electricity and
computers and smartphones and internet
and it's ubiquitous for you to be able
to build the future with all these
different tools and have all these
things at your fingertips
circling helps us get closer to that
goal of world peace we figure out how to
get into other people's shoes how to
relate with people that we normally
don't even know them that well and all
of a sudden were relating with them on
really deep vibes and this happens
across the planet with different people
that speak different languages with
different backgrounds different
demographics different ages you'd be
certainly someone that's 61 year 20 they
can be from a different part of the
world than you but all of a sudden you
realize you're both human you both have
emotions you both have these feelings
that come up from your heart from your
past and your family from what your
ambitions are who your lover is all
these different things that are just so
interestingly similar so damn it let's
figure out how to work together and
circling sure does help us do that all
right Alan what made this
when a mind becomes expanded to new
dimensions of thought it is known to be
as one of the most profound experiences
of someone's life and to be around a
group of people that are showing you
these beautiful examples and they're
going through these feelings of mind
expansion and heart expansion and
they're just growing so much and they're
vocalizing this they're teaching
everyone in the group this and it's not
just one person having it it's it's a
dozen people that are having it and it's
just some of the most profound
breakthroughs that that I've ever seen
and felt and been around and so that is
the greatest coolest aspect of being a
part of this event today and that's what
really keeps my mouth watering for more
and bringing in us to more people around
the world
imagine if before the United Nations sat
down that they all went and got into a
circle and that they all went and bonded
with each other about their feelings and
their oneness and imagine how different
the world would be if we weren't going
so crazy overpowering and money and
greed but we were a little bit more
willing to look at each other in the
eyes and say that hey you're human you
also have a very funny situation with
your family and in many ways it's [ __ ]
up and so what better way to talk about
that than by showing each other love
care respect and actually breaking into
breaking these these barriers that we
put up and saying that if you look at
Earth from the moon
there's no borders so let's figure out
how to work together